*best windows ever invented*
Hey how is going bros
My name is PewDiePieeee
today we're gonna play my favourite anime of all time (DRAGONBALLZ)
Tokyo Ghoul *oh*
*Silence*
i'm a real fan
that's why I have the attire
so
we're gonna play multiplayer
I will of coarse be my waifu
i will of course be my bae... my one and only.. Levi (Cheating On Marzia Hey Poods)
my one and only senpai levii
pewds kisses the screen
pewds confesses awkward love for hentai character
Oh how I love you <3
*japanese* (I'm pretty sure?)
*more japanese*
keep talking dirty to me levi!
pewds making unfunny joke
pewds confusedly navigating the menus
I've never played online before, this should be....
pewds attempts to make joke which falls flat
should be good
a lot of... a lot of players playing this game right now
pewds sees neckbeards like himself and gets ready to click in
a lot of
a lot of anime fans
how about this one??
pewds clicks in awkward loading screen
*people talking in the backround I think we are being attacked*
pewds after seeing 2 girls one cup
pewds brain trying to process human contact
pewds talking to randoms
do you guys like anime?
*weird computer echo thingy*
pewds attempting the whole human contact thing
i love anime, it's my favourite <3
pewds making another stupid joke
have you guys seen Naruto?? (nope)
awkward transition
pewds attempting to expand on unfunny joke
i - i can hear that you hear me
why are you ignoring me? (T^T)
helLOO?
fellow anime fans
why are you ignoring me?? (>_<)
Hey! onLY I CAN BE LEVI!
fakers
Bro calm down dude
you calm down
okay?
don't talk to me like dat
you don't fudging know me
???
aw shit it crashed
with
no mans sky out performing
everyones expectations, this-this game is really not letting down
hi fellow anime friend (^-^)/
shit
what am i doing wrong here?
welcome, welcome anime friends
please press "X"
so we can play together
great
let's go!
and attack
some titans
O-O-OOOOK-A-A-A-AAY
i have to warn you guys, i have at least 200 hours of experiance
try to keep up!
"-weirdest place something something"
sorry
i didn't catch that
you were talking to slow
(did he say egg???)
FUCK SAKE it crashes aLL THE TIME
let's switch to single playeruuu
so if you're not familiar with tokyo ghoul
it's basically
a bunch of barbie dolls came together
and decided to akka- attack mankind
OOOH SHIT
I'm gonna have to censor this video now
great
is he just gonna look at me??
alright let's take out his legs
i SWEAR I've seen a porno like this
OOH
MYY
GAWWD
*poods laughter* A.K.A *a dead pig*
is he just gonna stay like that!?
he's like
"well just come on
just fuck me"
what the fUCK IS HE DOING??
This game is absolutely FLAWLESS
is this some weird titan techno dance??
*epic dance mlg noscope drug music*
*dances out of the room*
listen, this isn't how gravity works!!
okay?
don't worry about it
I gotta say the combat is pretty awesome tho
i-i'm not gonna lie
look at that shit!
went RIGHT through his penis
NOW
the question that we're all wondering...
where is potato girl? (yeah where is she!?)
My favourite character (same!)
*eats potato*
...
*eating intensifies*
POTATO Girl
you were right there!
is this sexual??
you can buy a fucking duster!?
all my effort now
in life
is to get that duster
oh my gOD
this guy looks like he had a face lift (i think)
about 500 times
It seems like the game follows the anime very... very carefully
it's really cool actually
I always hated that guys haircut *at least its not as bad as yours*
it's so fucking annoying
I feel like I'm spooderman
instead of shooting web
i thrust
Eren is so fucking over-dramatic
wow, this game is so good
OH MY GAWD
He destroyed my salad stand..?
oh yeah you're fucked you're gone
don't ever fucking touch my salad again you piece of fucking shit
OOh
aww he got the apples
now you've really done it titans
*FABULOUSSSSS*
now that's a sexy one
that guy- WHAT THE FUCK
*lauging pig on helium*
wow what a great threat
*more laughter*
if you look too carefully, the game is so bad
i mean, there's no way that's gonna get repetitive.
wtf am i looking at?
What the fuUuUck
wait, wait, wait, my friend died
thank you
all i want, is the duster
that's all we're doing here
give me the duster, give me the fucking duster
where's the duster?
gimme the duster
oooOH MY GOD
this guy is literally me
the haircuts
in this anime
it's just the best
see i could even do the voice acting
look at this
(perfect imitation)
why are some of them so skinny?
i need to know their diets
yes, heh, actually, nevermind
i don't need to know their diet *pooods laughter*
OOH
*hysterical laughter*
THUMBNAIL
I FOUND IT
hommi
look at that shit
come on then
put it fucking in then
damn
the ga- the fucking flying around thing is really cool
alright?
you can't- ah... uuh...
uh
it-it's-it's real cool
I can't help but being a little turned on by this game
i don't know why
OH MY GOD he broke my house (rude)
mikasa, more like sukasa..?
am i right?
now what the fuck is that one doing?
the thing
that threatens our existence
despite its wonkiness though, I gotta say
it's really cool to be part of
the anime
"hey, how y'a doing now buddy"
"you mind if we come iiiin?"
"-and fist you?"
*poods laughter*
"I LOVE FISTING!!!"
i should be with the writer of this show
thank you very much
i wonder if this is confusing if you don't know anything about the anime
it's like
"why are all the naked people doing that?"
actually, it doesn't make sense if you watch the anime as well...
YEAHAHAAS
OOooOoOOH
YESSSS
this is all i wanted
*poods laughter*
LOOK IT THAT ONE'S STILL- *laughter*
just pretend you're a fucking wall!
it'll be okay!
oh look, there's me
*sounds of humanity dying away*
I'm telling you, they should use me!
come on, gimme the dusters
gimme the fucking dusters
i want the dusters
OOH
*laughter*
it's time to clean up!
OH SHIT HE GOT ME
what the fuck is that sound effect!!??
what the shIT IS THIS
WTF
That's the sound effect you went with!?
i can't
okay, you know what? enough
returning to camp
i think this game is pretty cool despite- uh- despite it's flaws
if you're an Attack On Titan fan you'll definately enjoy it
and if you're not, you might smnghihjlahw like
that's my official review thank you very much
but yeah, i like the game, i hope you enjoyed it too
and if you did, leave a like, and i'll see you on another video episode
love you guys SO much, SO MUCH
~~brofist~~